bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo avec à mes côtés
comme chaque semaine aude moracchini
bonjour bonjour alors dans l'actualité
cette semaine voilà les ministres
prévenu delphine batho a jugé son budget
mauvais réponse immédiate limogé l'ex
ministre accuse matignon d'être en proie
aux lobbys le point ministre évoque un
problème politique et de cohérence
gouvernementale
après mûre réflexion les verts ont
décidé de poursuivre l'aventuré il reste
donc au gouvernement
c'est une mesure sans précédent prises
par le conseil constitutionnel il
invalide les comptes de campagne 2012 de
nicolas sarkozy l'ancien président dans
un communiqué annonce qu'il ne siègera
pas au conseil retrouve du coup sa
liberté
l'ump est privé de 11 millions d'euros
lance une grande souscription nationale
c'est un vieux serpent de mer le texte
sur le non cumul des mandats a été
examiné par l'assemblée nationale
82% des députés ont au moins un mandat
local c'est dire si les parlementaires
ne sont pas vraiment emballés à l'idée
d'abandonner leur mandat en tout cas en
il en faudra choisir est avec nous pour
commenter cette actualité riche jean
christophe lagarde bonjour merci d'être
chaud sur ce plateau vous êtes député eu
délit de seine saint denis vous êtes
également président de la fed n'ont pas
la réserve fédérale américaine la force
européenne démocrate a en partie que
vous avez créé tout juste il ya tout
juste un an
si je ne me trompe et vous êtes l'un des
satellites on peut dire de la galaxie
udi est présidé par jean-louis borloo
alors à l'assemblée vous êtes également
porte-parole du groupe u10 on est allé
comme chaque semaine voire aux quatre
colonnes vos collègues députés pour voir
ce qu'ils pensent que vous regardez ses
jantes un homme qui a du talent
un homme qui est sympathique disponible
toujours souriant mais qui sait brettés
et c'est débattre
il ya toujours de bons arguments et qui
a d'habitat lité donc c'était un
excellent collègue même si je suis pas
d'accord sur tout avec lui c'est
quelqu'un que
que j'estime plutôt en fait c'est un
membre de l'opposition mais qui fait
preuve souvent de d'esprit constructif
dans les débats sur l'année qui vient de
s'écouler
finalement il est en commission des
finances il a été extrêmement discret et
en séance publique j'ai l'impression qui
a été aussi assez pudique donc c'est une
première année d'échauffement surmontant
son mandat parlementaire
il ya un peu atypique un élu du centre
droit de droite ont adhéré mais en
banlieue parisienne en banlieue rouge
on s'est quand même pas tous les jours
que tu es bien très dynamique qui s'est
implanté en direct à très difficile et
qui sait le tenir
franchement c'est bien c'est un député
très actif c'est un maire aussi qui sur
le terrain sauvage beaucoup de
conviction il a des idées qui sont pas
toujours les mêmes que les miennes
d'ailleurs mais je souhaite bonne chance
à ceux qui sapent la gare vous êtes
pudique et discret dit un autre porte
parole de groupe
thierry mandon et sa palette un
compliment dans sa bouche savoir c'est
que la commission des finances où je
viens de rentrer il ya une tradition
c'est que grosso modo les anciens ce
qu'on appelle des whip les principaux
orateurs se sont eux qui parlent tout le
temps et les autres n'ont quasiment
jamais la parole c'est sale et c'est ça
la réalité il faut manifestement du
temps pour avoir le droit de s'y
exprimer j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
dans l'hémicycle mais pas forcément sur
le même sujet en tissage après demande
et les autres n'avaient pas l'air de
dire ça ce qui prouve qu'on doit pas
s'intéresser au même sujet avec monsieur
monde allez jean christophe lagarde m'a
déroule évidemment toute l'actualité de
la semaine une actualité très importante
c'est le vix mauges âge de delphine
batho c'est ce qu'on va appeler le coup
de semonce de françois hollande
évincé pour ne pas avoir respecté la
sacro sainte règle de la solidarité
gouvernementale la ministre de
l'écologie a décidé de tout dire lors
d'une conférence de presse
écoutez la règle ses comptes le premier
ministre cette année a décidé de changer
de méthode en faisant les arbitrages
sans discussions directes avec les
ministres concernés
quelque chose a changé dans le
fonctionnement gouvernemental mon
éviction est aussi un message à mes ex
collègues pour leur dire que c'est fini
la collégialité au sein du gouvernement
certaines puissances économiques
n'acceptez pas le niveau d'ambition que
je fixais pour la transition énergétique
ce combat s'est cristallisée notamment
sur la question des gaz de schiste et
plus discrètement sur la réduction de la
part du nucléaire en france
ces forces dont je parle ne se sont pas
cachés de vouloir ma tête
mais si le gouvernement avait été
solidaires elle n'y seraient pas
parvenus est il normal que le patron de
l'entreprise vallourec directement
intéressés par l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste et puis annoncer ma
marginalisation des semaines à l'avance
devant des responsables de son
entreprise aux états unis que le patron
de vallourec disent que je suis un
désastre parce que je fais remparts au
gaz de schiste et que je veux réduire la
part du nucléaire c'est une chose qu'il
annonce ma mise à l'écart à l'avance
c'en est une autre de quelles
informations dispose est il pour être si
sûr de lui
jean christophe lagarde qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de ce point presse de
règlements de compte général ça c'est
inédit la part d'un ex ministre
je pense pas que ce soit un règlement de
compte je pense que l'expriment deux
choses d'abord
une déception envers la trahison
environnementale dont fait preuve ce
gouvernement on n'a jamais eu un
gouvernement aussi anti environnementale
que celui ci il a arrêté tout ce que
nous avions lancée sur la rénovation
énergétique ils arrêtent les grands
transports publics qui permettent
d'économiser il est en train de faiblir
sur la fiscalité écologique même s'il
avait la transition énergétique un peu
de temps avec une taxe également mais
vous avez raison il promet beaucoup mais
on a le président qui passe son temps à
renier tous ses engagements c'est le
président du ralliement et les
écologistes le savent bien ils viennent
d'essayer de sauver quelques petites
bribes là par le départ de bananes
bateau essayant de saisir l'occasion
oui ils vont obtenir 2 centimes ou 3
centimes sur diesel on vannes oc pardon
pardon ils vont fêter bardot questions
qui vont ils vont de lâcher de 300 types
de taxes supplémentaires sur les
français sur le diesel et on va nous
parler de révolution écologique
le plan de rénovation énergétique ou en
et id on n'est même pas à 6000
signatures par an quand on lance des 170
me lie à pattaya pas très longtemps les
grands transport qui sont abandonnés le
canal seine nord
tout ce qui permettait à notre pays
d'inventer et de se propulser vers
l'avant
les crédits recherche en la matière sont
en train de fondre non ils ont abandonné
et c'est ce que dit madame bateau toute
forme d'ambition écologique
il passe sa soupe d'africom aux couleurs
de saint jean christophe lagarde
pourquoi parce que la rigueur ne doit
toucher que ce secteur-là lesquelles la
culture dites moi quel est le secteur
gouvernemental qui perd 500 millions
d'euros cette année quel est le super
moment rien n'est sûr
et ce sans compter l'abandon de tous les
grands travaux c'est à dire de tous qui
prépare l'avenir
il ya des choix à faire mais attendez
pardon il ya eu le choix par exemple de
lancer pour plusieurs milliards d'euros
un contrat de génération qui pour
l'instant ne sert strictement à rien et
ne fonctionne pas et ne convainc
personne
il ya eu le choix de recruter des
milliers de personnes dans l'éducation
nationale qui coûte beaucoup plus cher
c'est ce sont des choix politiques mais
permettez nous de nous dire qu'il n'ya
pas en réalité de raison de sacrifier
ceux qui préparent à la fois l'avenir
c'est à dire en termes de ressources
naturelles de capacité à vivre sur notre
terre c'est le choix de ce gouvernement
après tout c'est son droit il peut se
faire élire avec les écolos et bonnet
une politique anti roms et vous
permettre
vous permettrait à l'opposition de dire
que le président du reniement qui depuis
le début de ce mandat jette une à une à
la rivière toutes les promesses qu'il a
faites
sauf quelques promesses sociétale très
franchement ça suffit et je comprends
que c'est propre miss madame bateau en
ai marre
il y en a d'autres elle mais madame
bateau elle même qui dit qu elle l
aurait cédé le gouvernement restait au
lobby aux forces économiques nucléaire
gaz de schiste a je pense en tout cas ce
qu'on sait c'est possible ça je pense
qu'elle pose une question sérieuse sur
les liens très particuliers que la
directrice de cabinet du président la
réplique très intime puisque c'est son
épouse avec quelqu'un qui est un grand
promoteur le patron de valois qui est un
grand promoteur du gage de 6 schiste et
c'est vrai que finalement madame bateau
la pauvre avant d'être évincé elle avait
depuis longtemps été marginalisés pas
que sur son budget sur bien dessus sur
tout le reste
cergy ce qui advient qui avale beaucoup
de couleuvres depuis quelques mois
finissait par avoir une indigestion ce
n'était pas à cause de bananes bateau
c'est à cause des trahisons monsieur
hollande
en tout cas les verts eux ont décidé de
rester dans le gouvernement ils font
toujours partie de la majorité
jusqu'à quand c'est toujours pas un
verre qui est ministre de
l'environnement on se demande à quel
point les socialistes se méfie des verts
pour ce qu'ils pourront refuser côté la
première je crois que c'était madame
briques
ça n'a pas marché on change de ministres
de l'environnement ont mais la malade
bato fou reconnaît lequel elle espérait
à l'époque d'être ministre de
l'intérieur ce pas tout à fait la même
chose
enfin madame bateau se met au job on
vire madame bateau avant va chercher
monsieur martin il faudrait peut-être
leur rappeler qu'il ya un ou deux
écologistes qui aimerait faire de
l'environnement je suis en forme
c'est pourquoi pas c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être en l'occurrence la raison pour
laquelle jamais un verre ne sera donnée
à l'environnement sous cette majorité
c'est ce que je dis nous avons le
gouvernement la majorité la plus anti
écolo de l'histoire de notre part ce que
répondent les verts en tout cas il y
avoir des garanties qui ont été demandés
par les verts vis-à-vis du gouvernement
c'est jérémy hartmann qui nous résume
tout ça il reste au gouvernement mais
réclame plus que jamais des engagements
au premier ministre saurez vous rendre
l'impôt écologiquement plus intelligent
et socialement plus juste
confirmez-vous les engagements
présidentiels sur la réduction de la
part d'une
r et la fermeture de fessenheim
confirmez-vous
l'interdiction de l'exploitation des gaz
de schiste il y aura-t-il une réforme de
la fiscalité dans le sens d'une
fiscalité plus écologique plus
incitative oui je vous réponds oui
nous n'attendrons pas la fin du
quinquennat françois hollande dès 2014
nos morceaux nous amorcerons cette
réforme en profondeur
oui à la fiscalité écologique oui aux
transports qui préserve l'environnement
et à l'efficacité énergétique
mais aucune précision concernant par
exemple le nucléaire ou le gaz de
schiste alors cette déclaration
d'intention suffira-t-elle à faire
rester les écologistes dans le pacte
majoritaire
comme souvent chez les verts les
interprétations divergent
si les écologistes d'abord tous les
matins se poser la question de savoir
s'ils sortent du gouvernement à crédible
il faut être sérieux quand on s'engage
c'est pas sur un coup de tête
la question de la présence des ministres
écologistes gouvernement reste posée
parce que à quoi ça sert d'avoir de bons
ministres
car de cécile duflot ee pascal canfin
sont de bons ministres cissé pour mener
si c'est pour participer à une politique
qui est l'exact contraire des
engagements qui ont été pris par le
président de la république et le premier
ministre mardi soir à l'issue d'une
réunion de crise les écologistes se sont
donnés jusqu'à la rentrée avant de
trancher définitivement la question ça
leur laisse encore un petit peu de temps
jusqu'à la rentrée
ils décideront un petit peu plus tard
une simple question sur quoi est ce que
vous allez juger la politique écologique
de françois hollande parce que c'est par
exemple la fermeture de fessenheim ou
une décision sur le gaz de schiste mais
où les de pardon une localité d'un
ensemble est gelée déjà jugé l'abandon
des grands travaux d'infrastructures de
transport et comme d'habitude le premier
ministre a un culot monstre que vous
finirez un jour par relever quand même
il annonce dans la même semaine la fin
de tous les chantiers de grandes lignes
ferroviaires que nous dont nous avions
besoin et il vient répondre pour faire
plaisir et faire semblant vis-à-vis de
madame bon pied les écolos que ils vont
s'occuper des transports on se fout de
nous on se fout de nous la politique
écologique du gouvernement nous l'avons
déjà jugé
regretté nous avons demandé sa relance
malheureusement elle ne vient pas et
c'est pas les trois francs six sous
qu'on va lâcher aux écolos pour qu' il
reste dans le gouvernement
d'ailleurs ils ont inventé une formule
extraordinaire ils sont dans la
participation sans soutien il soutient
ne rien faire par moi je constate qu'ils
ne soutiennent rien ou pas grand chose
du gouvernement qu'ils passent leur
temps à dénoncer les trahisons françois
hollande
en cela ils sont plutôt plus correct
vis-à-vis de leurs électeurs que les
élus socialistes
et puis disent mais par contre pour les
ministres les gardes parce que ça peut
toujours servir
bon c'est une façon de faire la
politique c'est une façon de faire de la
politique mais moi j'espère une seule
chose c'est qu'ils arrivent à être un
peu plus efficace au sein de la majorité
pour faire en sorte que cette majorité
soit un peu moins anti environnementale
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui promis de
venir dans les meetings de s'expliquer
sur la politique écologique du
gouvernement aujourd'hui voulu demander
des preuves non parce que chaque fois
que le premier il se raconte quelque
chose dans l'hémicycle et fait le
contraire le lendemain à matignon donc
bon s'il dit on va reprendre maintenant
le fil de la semaine
on a vu que delphine batho a dénoncé le
tournant de la rigueur
justement la rigueur mardi on en parle à
l'assemblée en ce mardi donc les députés
examinent le débat d'orientation pour
d'orientation budgétaire pardon pour
une formalité estivale généralement mais
cette année les débats prennent un
relief particulier avec les annonces de
cadrage des dépenses publiques notamment
cette fameuse réduction dont on a parlé
du budget du ministère de l'écologie
l'objectif est de ramener le déficit
public à 3 et demi pour cent du pib en
2014 dépenses réduites donc le point les
orientations avec rim benameur le budget
2014 s'annonce encore comme un budget de
rigueur
au total le gouvernement doit économiser
14 milliards d'euros pour éviter un
dérapage de son déficit pour tenir nos
engagements notre parole
la confiance dans l'action du
gouvernement dans l'action publique
c'est d'abord ça tenir nos engagements
nous avons pris des engagements sur la
réduction des déficits devant les
français nous en avons pris également
devant nos partenaires européens
même si françois hollande s'en défend
les fonctionnaires seront largement mis
à contribution avec un nouveau gel du
point d'indicé des suppressions de
postes ministères les plus touchés la
défense avec 7000 postes et bercy avec
2300 postes les budget de l'écologie de
l'agriculture et de la culture sont
aussi revus à la baisse
en revanche les secteurs jugés
prioritaires éducation sécurité emploi
bénéficieront de dix mille créations de
postes en tout grâce à cette réduction
des dépenses de l'état le gouvernement
espère économiser 9 milliards d'euros et
il compte sur des baisses dans ses
dépenses sociales retraites et sécurité
sociale à hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros
le volet dépenses est donc bouclée il
faut maintenant trouver des recettes
un casse tête alors que françois
hollande promet qu'il n'y aura pas de
nouvelle hausse d'impôts l'an prochain
l'opposition n'y crois pas
contrairement aux multiples promesses de
monsieur hollande les impôts vont
inéluctablement augmenté en 2014 on le
voit le budget 2013 a dérapé le déficit
budgétaire va se creuser au moins 20
milliards d'euros vont manquer le
gouvernement doit à tout prix maintenir
le déficit public à 3,5 pour cent du pib
un objectif quasi impossible à atteindre
dans une période de croissance nulle
dont jean-christophe lagarde vous êtes
membre de la commission des finances
tout ça vous concerne au premier chef
pour la suite
françois hollande a dit pas de nouveaux
impôts est ce que c'est une promesse
nabeul évidemment non et d'ailleurs il y
croyait pas lui-même s'est pour la
première qu'il travaille depuis qu'il
est président de la république parce
qu'on pourrait encore comprendre qui
fait qu'ils fassent des promesses avant
d'être élu pour être élu free depuis
qu'il est élu il via la télévision et il
fait exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
annonce quinze jours trois semaines
après et là pour le compte
tout le monde sait qu'il ne peut pas ne
pas augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires ils ont prévu de le faire
ils sont en train d'ailleurs de le
préparer d'hésiter entre guillemets de
savoir à qui ils vont faire les poches
et grosso modo faut quand même rappeler
un peu l'histoire juillet 2012 7
milliards de plus l'an dernier 30
milliards de plus
ça fait 37 et cette année il leur faudra
entre 6 et 12 13 milliards projet de loi
entre 6 rectifié je vais revenir sur
autre chose entre 6 et 12 milliards de
plus parce que vos 14 milliards vous
avaler ça dans le reportage comme des
économies où sont les économies de 14
milliards
ce sont les mêmes comptes dont on nous
expliquait par exemple quand on dépensé
un milliard et demi pour les emplois
d'avenir on allait faire des économies
pour compenser elles sont jamais venus
vous voulez même que les deux milliards
et demi qui devait venir en économie
pour compenser les contrats de
génération
on n'a jamais vu ses économies c'est pas
parce qu'on les annonce un jour et que
la faculté d'oubli dans une démocratie
médiatique est grande que à la
commission des finances où dans les
comptes publics ça disparaît parce que
la difficulté c'est que c'est pas 9
milliards de baisses des dépenses et
éviter qu'elles augmentent de 9
milliards alors qu'elles auraient pu non
ce sont des vraies économies dont on a
besoin
quand vous d'ailleurs votre tableau
était intéressante dix mille créations
dessus précédé de deux créations de
postes 7900 suppression vous croyez que
ça fait des économies quand vous créez
600 postes
vous appelez ça l'économie et la
communication gouvernementale en temps à
faire gober ça le problème c'est que ça
ne le fait pas gober aux marchés ça ne
le fait pas kobe comment diriger la
commission européenne et que nous sommes
en grande difficulté alors oui il
faudrait un collectif budgétaire
mais ça c'est encore plus extravagant
pour l'année 2013 puisque là on parlait
de 2014 pour l'année 2013 on nous
annonçait un déficit à 3% comme objectif
nous serons au moins à 4%
parce qu'ils nous ont fait rentrer en
séries en récession avec le gourdin
fiscal utilisé depuis l'année dernière
pardon vous nous l'accorderez la
récession ne date pas de l'arrivée de
françois hollande on l a commencé comme
l'homme la récession en elle-même après
annonce je ne pense pas que ce soit un
débat un collectif budgétaire qui vient
alourdir les impôts des français 2 7
milliards d'euros
privé par exemple tous ceux qui font des
heures supplémentaires qui sont pas des
gens riches les salariés les ouvriers
les fonctionnaires c'est pas des
milliardaires
quand vous leur pic et effectivement
plusieurs milliards d'euros que vous
avez une baisse du pouvoir d'achat de -0
9 c'est pas l'héritage chez les
décisions du gouvernement actuel faut
arrêter de s'abriter derrière l'héritage
c'est trop facile il
depuis un an un gouvernement qui prend
des décisions qui a augmenté les impôts
de 37 milliards d'euros
et on va parler d'héritage on se fout du
monde là encore pardon de vous le dire
aujourd'hui la france est en récession
et sa date du dernier trimestre 2012
c'est pas tout à fait rien la crise du
logement et l'effondrement de la
production de logement dans notre pays
c'est depuis la fin 2012 et ça crée
effectivement un effet récessif lourd le
fait que pour la première fois le
pouvoir d'achat baisse dans notre pays
de -0 9% presque - % et encore on n'a
pas tout vu
parce que là on parle de 2012 on va
parler de 2013 c'est à dire une fois que
vous avez rajouté à 30 milliards en
question est ce que ça veut dire que les
efforts qui sont faits actuellement les
demandes d'économie qu'on essaye de
faire un petit peu partout c'est
suffisant ou ce n'est pas suffisant
menée par dont il n'y a pas d'économies
dans le budget de l'état aujourd'hui
fort le budget de la grée de
l'agriculture de la culture qu'on
évoquait à l'instant mais c'est pardon
c'est marginal c'est l'épaisseur du
trait pas pour vos besoins et demi
qu'elle allait verser l'épaisseur du
trait par rapport aux besoins et
l'essentiel se fera dans la fiscalité
ce n'est pas parce que on peut avoir
envie de croire à ce que raconte le
gouvernement le moi vous savez je suis
un type assez que quelqu'un disait tout
à l'heure assez pragmatique est assez
ouvert quand ils sont arrivés en 2012
j'ai écouté ce qui nous racontait je me
suis dit bon ils disent qu'ils vont
faire de nouvelles dépenses qu'elles
sont engagées par les économies j'ai vu
les nouvelles dépenses j'ai jamais vu
des économies bon quand on me raconte la
deuxième fois de la deuxième fois la
même falaise
je vais pas la gober et je vais pas la
valider et je veux dire aux français il
faut être très clair la fiscalité qui a
déjà augmenté de 37 milliards qui a mis
notre équipe économie en panne fait
baisser le pouvoir d'achat des français
va s'alourdir avec un paradoxe
invraisemblable invraisemblable c'est
que en augmentant les impôts les
recettes rentrent moins bien justement
parce qu'ils nous ont fait rentrer en
récession et donc leurs recettes qui va
continuer à être d'augmenter les impôts
la fiscalité écologique parce qu'elle
est écologique ne serait pas fisc était
bien sûr que les fiscalités la tva
cela dit ça ne marchera pas ce serait
évidemment je pense qu ils nous
pourrissent tout tout droit à la
catastrophe mais c'est ce qu'une vision
dès le
le budget 2012 et pardon de dire que
nous avons eu raison sur quasiment tous
les points
vous allez faire entrer le pays en
récession nous y sommes vous allez faire
exploser le chômage malheureusement
c'est le cas baisser le pouvoir d'achat
des français
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l'insee
s'est fait pour justement être le juge
de paix et tout ce que nous avions
annoncé nous avons demandé qu'il y ait
un plan de relance
nous avons proposé d'y participer sur au
moins sur les problèmes sur lesquels en
réalité nous sommes d'accord expliquez
moi quand aujourd'hui la production de
logements s'est effondré de quasiment
60% dans certaines régions expliquez moi
pourquoi attendre pour baisser la tva le
1er janvier 2014
on perd du temps on perd des emplois on
perd des entreprises cette politique du
gouvernement ne fait qu'une chose
attendre 15 jours peut-être la reprise
américaine la reprise chinoise la
reprise surtout sans rien faire attendre
six les gourdins fiscal utilisé contre
les entreprises et les français
reviennent
moi je pense qu un président c'est là
pour décider pas pour attendre bon voilà
ça c'est dit aussi on va passer au
mercredi avec ses textes qui elle est
examinée à l'assemblée nationale sur le
non cumul des mandats
c'était une promesse de françois
hollande alors certes elle a du mal à
passer pour une majorité parlementaire
et même pour les socialistes
en tout cas mais il fallait quand même
s'attaquer aux textes exemple ne plus
parler députés ne pourront plus cumuler
avec une fonction d'un mandat local
évidemment on parle de député et de
maire c'est un exemple détaille avec
jean baptiste daoulas c'est un cumulard
repenti qui se présente devant les
députés
pendant dix ans manuel valls a été
député maire d'evry demanda difficiles à
concilier au quotidien je sais la
réalité des séances de nuit qu'il faut
cumuler avec des conseils de quartier je
sais la réalité des auditions commission
qu'il faut cumuler avec des réunions de
pilotage de chantier je sais la réalité
de la rédaction d'un rapport
parlementaire qu'il faut cumuler avec
des situations imprévues parfois
l'urgence qui marquent la vie d'une
collectivité
et pour lesquels il faut être
impérativement sur le terrain sans
surprise les arguments de manuel valls
ne convainquent pas l'opposition
le mp accuse le ministre et sa majorité
de faire preuve d'hypocrisie face au
cumul
combien parmi vous ont un pedigree
beaucoup plus imposante que le nôtre en
matière de cumul passé et aujourd'hui
vous êtes là bourgeois de calais
repentant de vos turpitudes présumé du
passé vous prétendez rénover la
démocratie et que faites vous vous
affadissent et la représentation
nationale
la discussion promet mme une tournure
assez inhabituel dans l'hémicycle sous
les acclamations de l'ump ce sont les
radicaux de gauche qui se montrent les
plus virulents avec les socialistes
vous avez décidé d'éliminer les à lui
pour les remplacer par les
fonctionnaires du parti socialiste vous
nous invitez un vaste hara kiri à nous
autres radicaux
nous refusons ce que vous nous proposez
en termes d'hara kiri une séance
turbulente qui fait figure de tour de
chauffe pour manuel valls l'opposition
au texte sera encore plus marquée au
sénat alors vous avez participé aux
débats dans la nuit surtout de jeudi à
vendredi jusqu'à 4 heures du matin dans
l'hémicycle du début à la fin
aussi depuis qu'on interroge nos invités
sur ce plateau et nous disent ancrage
local
est-ce que c'est pas un peu facile
finalement moi c'est très facile c'est
déjà la présentation d'un reportage qui
parle des cumulards qu'est ce que c'est
quand à aider quelqu'un qui cumule c'est
quelqu'un qui exerce de fonction à la
fois une fonction exécutive où vous
gérer quelque chose et une fonction
représentative vous essayez entre
guillemets de porter un certain nombre
d'idées notamment tiré de ce que vous
gérez qui vous permet d'avoir une
réalité très concrète entre les mains
donc oui ça peut être un ancrage local
mais la question n'est pas la
présentation de toute façon avec un
exécutif aussi populiste que celui que
nous avons qui nous a fait le coup
complètement débile sur la transparence
la transparence du patrimoine des élus
ce qui est intéressant c'est de savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils ont gagné pendant leur
mandat parce qu'ils avaient avant ça n'a
aucun intérêt mais passons ça marche
parce que de toute façon ça fait vendre
et toute la presse écrite et le peuple à
30 ans on lui lâche et on l'est on lui
lâche 1,9 qu'il va ronger
on est dans la même chose mais par
contre cette hausse est dangereux et
c'est ce que j'ai voulu démontrer dans
une motion de points de procédure cette
hausse démagogique et dangereux
pourquoi parce que nous ne sommes pas et
on nous compare souvent à l'allemagne
aux etats unis nous ne sommes pas un an
tan dung et à décentraliser les pouvoirs
qui sont conférés aux locaux dans ces
pays-là leur capacité d'adaptation
législative à la réalité de leur région
n'existe pas en france premier point est
donc on va avoir des lois totalement
éloigné du terrain avec des gens qui
sont les hommes qui sont pas dans des
gens il faut expliquer qu'il faut
expliquer très concret il faut en
l'occurrence que les gens comprennent
qu'on va faire une assemblée
d'apparatchiks deuxième chose et c'est
plus grave parce que ça va aggraver les
déséquilibres de la vème république
aujourd'hui les parlementaires qui ont
cet ancrage local
ils peuvent résister au pouvoir exécutif
et c'est encore plus important pour les
députés que pour les sénateurs parce que
les députés maintenant ils sont élus en
même temps que le président de la
république ça veut dire qu'en réalité
tous les députés de la majorité sont
soumis à la volonté présidentielle
d'ailleurs vous le verrez dans ce texte
de loi
il ya une majorité de parlementaires y
compris aux socialistes qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec ce texte de loi mais on
finir par le voter comme avec novillo
mais dans ces cas-là supprimons
l'assemblée nationale et décidons que le
président de la république désigne les
godillots qui votent comme un seul homme
quand vous avez lu les dissidents qui
l'ouvrent et qui dit je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est parce qu'il a un ancrage
local
le jour il l'aura plus il sera soumis
aux décisions de son parti pour sa
réélection et à ce moment-là il à faire
moi quand manuel valls dit il est
impossible de cumuler des séances de
nuit avec des conseils de quartier des
commissions avec des pilotages de
chantier etc
parce qu'il n'a pas un peu raison à ce
que vous vous êtes vous êtes à
l'assemblée combien de jours par semaine
le maire françois lemaire de rancière de
franchement même si il faut faire 35
heures c'est impossible mais mois 35
heures je les fais en 48 heures voilà et
la réalité c'est que j'étais jeune ça
prend de l'âge et pg c'est mon problème
tant que j'accepte de l'assumer et est
ce que ça fait de moi un député il
efficace ou un meriem efficace c'est pas
le sentiment que j'ai c'est pas le
sentiment que les certitudes et mes
citoyens partagerai avec vous me
semble-t-il
je vous ferai une observation cette nuit
j'étais jusqu'à 3h30 du matin en séance
ici ce matin j'étais à 8h15 dans sur un
chantier dans ma commune puis après j'ai
eu une réunion sur la sécurité des
salariés de la ville au travail
j'arrive ici je fais cette émission je
reçois ici une délégation d'enseignants
en colère contre la politique du
gouvernement
pardon et je vais continuer ma journée
oui parce que je ne travaille pas 35
heures par semaine parce que je n'ai pas
de week-end que j'ai moins de vacances
et parce que pardon de le dire
70% de mon activité de parlementaire je
la tire de mon expérience de maire je ne
pourrais pas la voir autrement et gelé
d'hier soir dans l'hémicycle
ça fait douze ça fait 11 ans ou douze
ans que je suis député nous enfumer
raison je suis député
combien de fois des gens sont venus me
voir comme député dans mes permanences
de députés pour me poser des problèmes
législatives moins de 5
on vient nous demander du boulot des
logements des aides contre telle ou
telle administration
par contre comme maire j'en ai vu des
problèmes législatifs et y compris
certains contribuer à régler puisque
nous avons voté la semaine dernière par
dont ces bi hebdo si je peux me
permettre un texte en porte c'est
peut-être cette semaine un projet de loi
sur la consommation
cette semaine qui a permis de créer
répertoire national du crédit sur lequel
je me bats depuis 2003 dix ans pour
arriver à convaincre ce que cette idée
était bonne qu'elle a été régulièrement
rejetées par le ps et l'ump aujourd'hui
c'est la loi eh ben ça sert à quelque
chose des tribus locales parce que quand
vous êtes en vous êtes en train de gérer
les situations de surendettement des
gens vous vous rendez compte ou sa
cloche quand vous en entendez parler
dans un colloque de votre parti vous
faites simplement une idée qui est
purement idéologique et pas réel dans la
vie des gens je vous propose de passer
au jeudi jean-christophe lagarde c'est
l'ump qui fait la quête après
l'annulation des comptes de campagne
et oui c'est la très mauvaise nouvelle
du jour pour l'ump le conseil
constitutionnel invalide les comptes de
campagne 2012 de nicolas sarkozy pour
cause de dépassement de plus de 400000
euros
résultat le candidat doit payer de
l'ancien candidat loupé de sa poche les
10 millions d'euros que devait verser
l'état
l'ump s'engage à payer et pour cela le
parti fait appel à la générosité des
français c'est une première on écoute
l'appel de jean françois copé
j'appelle les militantes et les
militants qui depuis tant de l'année
s'engage sur le terrain au milieu des
français pour promouvoir les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres
j'appelle les sympathisantes et les
sympathisants qui chaque jour s'engagent
plus nombreux à nos côtés j'appelle
aussi les françaises et les français qui
ne partagent pas forcément toutes nos
idées
lady considère indispensable vital même
vite qu'un grand parti de droite et du
centre s'attelle à préparer l'avenir des
enfants en souffrance à répondre à la
grande souscription nationale que je
vais lancer dès lundi afin de barrer la
route à celles et ceux qui rêvent plus
d'une seule chose voir l'espace
politique français monopolisée par la
gauche par les partis extrémistes et ce
vendredi nicolas sarkozy a choisi
facebook pour communiquer je vous
demande de m'aider en vous un mobilisant
dit-il l'ancien président a promis de
s'engager pour garantir une expression
démocratique libre dans notre pays
jean christophe lagarde c'est parti
c'est le réengagement officielle de
nicolas sarkozy dans la vie politique je
crois pas mais assurément si cette
décision ait lieu puisque c'était lui le
candidat il aussi
à contribuer au redressement de l'ump et
très franchement c'est l'écumé des
vagues en tout cas mon avis c'est pas le
problème principal le problème principal
c'est que cette décision qui doit être
respectée c'est la plus haute
juridiction française
elle pose des difficultés pour l'avenir
et si hier je voyais ici dans
l'hémicycle et socialistes se marrer
comme des tordus il ya un problème quand
même qu'il faut qu'on règle est qu'il
faut qu'on règle par la loi un ancien
président de la république
forcément et françois hollande sera un
ancien président de la république pour
un président de la république sortant
jusqu'au dernier jour et comme
évidemment il sera candidat parce qu'ils
le sont tous
il va avoir le même problème mais ce
problème il faut qu'on le règle parce
que imaginait que une seconde que le
président de la république élu le 6 mai
2012 ce soit nicolas sarkozy la décision
d'hier ferait que nous n'aurions pas à
l'heure où je parle de président de la
république et qu'on recommencera de
l'élection présidentielle c'est par
décision ça ne s'est pas non pas du tout
je suis en train de dire que ce n'est
pas un petit sujet que l'invalidation
des comptes à l'élection présidentielle
puisse annuler l'élection présidentielle
parce que c'est ce qui se serait produit
dans ce cas-là premier pour un deuxième
point c'est quand même un peu compliqué
et je pense qu'il faut à la fois que la
commission des comptes de campagne le
conseil constitutionnel les
parlementaires si nécessaire enfin c'est
un véritable vade mecum de ce qui est du
rôle du président de la république
jusqu'au bout et financé par l'état
quand ils se déplacent ils se déplacent
pas tout seul lille se déplace avec
toutes les scores etc
qu'est ce qui est à celle charge il peut
pas aller à n'importe quel endroit si
jamais il doit dormir quelque part et
ces caisses qui est quel est le partage
qui est de la bobine de partage builder
du truc c'est l'histoire de meetings de
villepinte
moi je pense qu'il ya quand même besoin
là aussi qu'on clarifie parce que
financée à 50 50 par le parti est pas
comment vous définissez jeudi rêve avec
un taux d intérêt la décision du conseil
mondial le plus clair je pense qu'il
faut clarifier les règles parce que ce
qui est valable pour l'élection à la
présidence d'un public c'est plus grave
parce que c'est le président de la
république c'est valable aussi dans
d'autres élections
il ya quand même des choses où il faut
que les gens connaissent les règles du
jeu avant pour passer pendant un moment
en qu'après d'amour quand même sur ce
qu'a dit nicolas sarkozy c'est quoi
c'est contraint et forcé qu'il est
obligé de sortir du bois aujourd'hui
non je crois pas qu'ils aient contraint
et forcé il fait le choix alors qu'il
est victime à la fois d'un lynchage
judiciaire depuis un certain temps et là
d'une décision qui met sa famille
politique son parti politique en partie
de sa responsabilité d'ailleurs
puisqu'il était le candidat c'est lui
qui a fait les comptes c'est bon ils les
voient en difficulté je pense qu'au
contraire on lui reprocherait de laisser
tomber leur dire allez vous débrouiller
si je comprends bien
jean françois copé lance une
souscription sarkozy dit je vous demande
d'aller aider cette souscription
c'est après tout le meilleur bailleurs
de fonds de l'ump et il serait dommage
d'un parti politique de droite comme
l'ump disparaisse pour que pour des
raisons financières
franchement si je m'engage pour la
garantie d'une expression démocratique
libre c'est un engagement personnel
c'est à dire que ça y est c'est reparti
non non ça c'est ce que vous avez envie
d'écrire parce qu'il vous manque
tellement
mais la réalité c'est plutôt que si un
parti comme l'ump qui est un grand parti
de droite pas trop du centre annonçant
ce matin de droite vient à ne plus avoir
les moyens de fonctionner ça va poser un
problème démocratique dans notre pays
aujourd'hui le parti socialiste exercent
tous les pouvoirs majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale il marche sur pied
le sénat et piétinent les habits du
sénat peut en permanence passeront aux
résidentes résidence de présidence de la
république gouvernement tous les
pouvoirs locaux larges influences on va
dire sur la politique industrielle et
médiatiques dans notre pays il faut
peut-être qu'il ya une opposition encore
sinon on va se retrouver en russie alors
justement vous parlez du sénat ça se
passe jeudi le sénat a infligé une sorte
de camouflet au gouvernement sur le
texte sur la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
c'était la grande réforme voulue par
françois hollande en matière de
constitution mais les sénateurs et bien
au non voulu autrement les explications
de faustine saint geniès c'est un coup
de théâtre dont seul le sénat le secret
aujourd'hui à la surprise générale la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature est adopté mais une réforme
vidé de sa substance
premier acte grâce à un jeu
d'amendements les sénateurs rejette le
coeur du texte la réforme de la
composition du csm qui prévoyait une
parité entre magistrats et non
magistrats
dans ces conditions le ps et les
écologistes préfèrent s'abstenir
le sort du texte est scellée dans le
vote final les trois groupes de gauche
écolo ps et radicaux se sont abstenus en
pas voté contre
parce qu'il restait quand même mais
partie de la réforme mais se sont
abstenus ump centre et radicaux vote
pour un amendement centriste et même
adopté obligeant le gouvernement à
suivre l'avis du csm pour les
nominations de magistrats du parquet
comme c'est déjà le cas pour ceux du
siège
en l'absence de majorité au sénat
l'opposition de profite donc pour
dénaturer une réforme emblématique du
gouvernement la réforme était bouclé
nous n'étions pas d'accord cette façon
sur le sur le fond de la réforme à
partir de ce moment là il doit y avoir
qu'un échec au sénat mais un échec
positif puisqu'on a quand même voté un
texte pense pas que ce soit une victoire
pour l'opposition c'est surtout une
victoire sur pour la conception que nous
avons la justice un vote qui déçoit
profondément la garde des sceaux qui
s'était beaucoup investi dans cette
réforme
la disposition qui ont été adoptées par
le sénat changent profondément la nature
de la réforme
par conséquent je ne peux pas vous dire
que les gens soient satisfaites
le gouvernement vient de suspendre la
réforme du csm impossible dans ces
conditions de réunir les parlementaires
en congrès à versailles
chaque année sauf la garde envers
longtemps d'un nouveau concept à l'échec
positif c'est bien ça va coûter
l'échec programmé le gouvernement fait
semblant de vouloir réformer la
constitution quand on veut réformer la
constitution et quant à ma fan majorité
pour ça on discute avec l'ensemble de sa
majorité d'abord parce que c'est quand
même dans la majorité que la mer ce
cadre jean marc ayrault avait avait un
petit peu consulté tous les chefs de
partis et s'était aperçu notamment sur
le droit de vote des étrangers n'y
arriverait pas non non non pas du tout
son droit de vote des étrangers ils
peuvent parfaitement réformer la
constitution qu'est ce qui les en
empêche
le président de la république se
présente devant les français il dit je
vais accorder le droit de vote aux
étrangers
il se trouve qu'il n'a pas de
possibilité il a été élu malgré cela il
n'a pas de possibilité de faire voter le
parlement il a une possibilité ça
s'appelle le référendum
ça demandait aux français de valider sa
promesse électorale pourquoi ne fait il
pas il préfère encore la trahir celle là
aussi il lui suffit d'aller en
référendum
ne me dites pas que le président de la
république aurait peur du peuple
français donc s'il trouve pas de
majorité au sein du parlement pour le
faire qu'ils aillent devant le peuple
français par référendum
pardon
je vous apprends que sur scène mais ils
n'en trouvent pas parce qu ils ne
discutent pas monsieur qu'est ce qui
choque le pardon il paraît pas si lourd
à cause si vous lisez pas répéter ce
qu'ils disent non désolé qu'est ce qui
choque par exemple madame taubira dans
notre reportage on dit c'est que le
gouvernement serait obligé de sueur de
la nomination des procureurs de suivre
le csm c'est plus d'indépendance à
l'achat et quoi il faudrait que
finalement pour modifier la constitution
là il ya une forme de police de la
pensée dirigé par le gouvernement et
puis tout ce qu'ils vont proposer
nous devons accepter moi j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi il n'y a pas de
référendum sur droit de vote des
étrangers j'aimerais savoir pourquoi on
a mis ce texte là l'ordre du jour et
parce que moi je suis prêt à voter des
réformes de la constitution par exemple
celles qui prévoient que l'ancien les
anciens présidents de la république ne
siège pas au sein du conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour du parlement
parce qu'on se fout de nous pardon c'est
de l'hypocrisie la plus totale et c'est
du reniement une fois de plus il ya
possibilité de réformer la constitution
si on discute et je vous ferez remarquer
qu'en 2008 nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas
de majorité pour faire voter une réforme
de la constitution
il a discuté avec les parlementaires de
l'opposition d'ailleurs à l'époque
certains d'entre eux s'étaient public
s'appelait manuel valls arnaud
montebourg il a ouvert des droits
nouveaux il a pas fait passer sa réforme
il n'a pas fait pas c'est que ces idées
à lui il a fait aussi il a tenu compte
des idées les autres d'ailleurs la nôtre
quand il s'agit aujourd'hui d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
n'a pas été mis en oeuvre par sarkozy et
dont j'attends que le gouvernement qui
le réclamer à grands prix identique
lorsque la sarkozie pas du tout je dis
ça je dis que ça n'a pas été mis en
oeuvre n'annonce pas pardon je vais leur
pardon je les cite et deux fois et à
votre demande sauf cette fois ci et je
dis qu'en 2008
ça n'a pas été mis je peux vous répondre
quand même
ça n'a pas été mis en oeuvre par nicolas
sarkozy que de l'opposition de l'époque
demandé à ce référendum citoyen suite au
fait que nous n'ayons imposé dans la
réforme constitutionnelle
elle ne met pas en oeuvre aussi quand
vous voulez modifier les règles du jeu
c'est simple en fait je vais faire en
une phrase quand vous voulez modifier
les règles du jeu vous faites en sorte
que tout le monde soit d'accord sur la
vague du jeu vous n'arrivez pas en
disant ça c'est mes règles et je vous
demande d'être d'accord parce qu'à ce
moment là ça marche pas ça marche alors
de crocodile sur la réforme du csm
bardon sur le droit de vote des
étrangers référendum
allez-y soyez courageux pour une fois
monsieur le président de la république
si vraiment vous croyez dans ce que vous
dites est troisième
comment dirais-je objet le conseil
constitutionnel on a vu hier ça avait
une importance il ne faut plus que les
anciens présidents de la république y
siègent vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui on est à trois membres
sur 2 sur 12 et que si françois hollande
d' aventure se représenter aux élections
présidentielles avec le peuple français
n'est pas la mauvaise idée de le réélire
on en aurait 4 sur 13 ça devient
indécent c'est plus une assemblée de
sages c'est sans les anciens combattants
jean christophe lagarde dans quelques
mois vous vous pencherez sur une grande
réforme celle de la réforme pénale et
pénitentiaire
hier le président du sénat s'est rendu
dans une prison à fleury mérogis en
banlieue parisienne reportage marie
brémond fleury mérogis le plus grand
centre pénitentiaire d'europe acquis
presque 4000 détenus
le président du sénat et le sénateur
andré weil murs viennent d'observer
vérifier les conditions dans lesquelles
travaillent les surveillants mais
également les conditions de vie des
prisonniers comme ici au centre des
jeunes détenus que voilà
ces métiers qui n'a pas fait leur job de
la rénovation
mais comme dans toutes les prisons de
france le gros problème reste la
surpopulation carcérale a fleuri le taux
d'occupation est de 140 % pour la
directrice de la maison d'arrêt des
hommes
il faut repenser les pelles et favoriser
les aménagements pour des très courtes
peines pourquoi ne pas envisager une
alternative alors j'ai pas de dire c'est
pas à moi de donner les orientations
précises à ce niveau là mais privilégier
autre chose que l'incarcération pour
faire baisser les effectifs en prison à
fleury-mérogis la situation est sans
doute meilleur qu'ailleurs pas plus de
deux détenus par cellule et la prison
est en travaux depuis 2002 pour une
rénovation complète à horizon 2018
échanges et visites est une évidence
pour jean pierre bel à quelques mois de
l'examen par le parlement de la réforme
pénale avant le début de l'automne
ce sera donc clairement clairement
exprimés les sénateurs devront se faire
avancer ce sujet la france fait encore
figure de mauvaise élève en europe elle
est régulièrement épinglée par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
les conditions indignes de ces prisons
jean christophe lagarde en tant que
parlementaire vous avez déjà visité
quatre prisons c'est bien ça depuis
douze ans j'ai visité quatre prises
parce que ça la surpopulation par
émission moralement ça fait partie de
nos missions droit d'y aller non
seulement on a le droit mais moi
j'estime que nous avons le devoir moral
de le faire je suis président du sénat
veut que ce soit une obligation
je préfère souvent que les
parlementaires soient obligés par la
morale que par la loi parce que plus ça
va plus on les prend pour en fin de
compte la surpopulation notamment
surpopulation mauvaises conditions de
détention non accès à des services
essentiels que sont la santé
bien souvent les consultations médicales
qui sont encore insuffisamment nombreux
et surtout on le rend les fait pas assez
travaillé en prison et on ne forme pas
suffisamment ce sale et notre système
pénitentiaire par dont il reproduit la
criminalité au dieu de la stopper
il ya une raison simple à ça il faut
mettre deux fois plus d'argent pour le
compte tout à l'heure en parler
d'économie pas sur ça il faut mettre
deux fois plus d'argent que ce que nous
mettons aujourd'hui dans nos prisons
c'est pas populaire parce que comme ils
ont fauté on veut plus les voir parmi
nous et leur donner de l'argent mais
c'est pas leur donner de l'argent c'est
faire en sorte que quand ils ressortent
il recommence pas parce que quand ils
commencent ils nous pourrissent la vie
ça fera sûrement partie en tout cas de
la grande réforme pénale qui aura lieu à
l'automne prochain l'on peut toujours
l'espérer
merci beaucoup jean christophe lagarde
merci d'avoir été avec nous pendant ces
45 minutes et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même lieu même heure